deux restaurants les pieds dans l'eau
quaida et le shell ces établissements
sont i bien en règle avec l'urbanisme et
le droit de passage sur le bord de mer
est il bien respecté autant de questions
qui amène la sopam art à la mairie de
case-pilote ce matin mais un comité
d'accueil les attend et c'est pour
soutenir le restaurateur qu'ils sont là
ce matin
les écologistes sont surpris et ce n'est
pas fini le maire devra ramener le calme
mesdames et messieurs l'éducation ne
s'achète pas au marché nous les
respectons nous les recevons
cordialement les écoutons et nous
répondrons il est vrai que les pilotins
sont venus en masse et resteront en
question sont populaires pour les
emplois qu'ils créent et l'animation
apportée dans le brevet mais pour l'aso
pamart l'un d'eux empêcherait l'un livre
circulation sur la plage l'autre n'a pas
encore d'un côté pour ne pas les
problèmes ça va bien pour nous note dans
l'égalité des médiévales ont pas fini on
l'a pas fait mais manque à mon âge l'ia
et pourra du bon d'accord moi c'est pas
dit semblant chinois le maire lui
soutient fortement ces établissements
précisons qu'il a lui-même rappelé le
droit de passage et le libre accès à ces
installations sur l'espace public même
exigence pour l'autre restaurant où la
haute et serait en cours de
régularisation
je ne soutiendrai jusqu'au bout et par
contre il faudra qu'ils respectent la
loi et loi ou pas loi moi je n'aurais
jamais permis qu'on empêche à des gens
de circuler et ça même si la loi ne
l'imposé pas je l'aurais moi en tant que
maire imposé on ne permet pas à des gens
de bloquer le passage le bien de tout le
monde est le bien de tout le monde et le
front de mer appartient à tout le monde
la venue de la soupe à maraka ce pilote
est bien inspiré de plaintes de
résidents qui ne se manifesteront pas ce
matin la foule présente elle veut
maintenir l'activité
saadoune vraiment india la ville vous il
ya des gens qui faisaient que passer une
à nationale sont entrés dans la ville
c'est entrer dans la boue avec les
restaurants bon il faudra autant
d'entrées de visites et de connaître la
ville ça c'est un bon temps et puis tenu
par des jeunes tenu par des jeunes
tournent de travail mais nous n'avons ni
roi ça et si il y à un mouvement et de
la population en faveur d'une comme le
dit le maire et 2
d'une dynamique pour quatre pilotes il
ya aucun problème mais ce n'est pas
parce que l'on essaie de mettre une
dynamique soucaze d'une autre que l'on
peut faire n'importe quoi dans n'importe
quelles conditions
affaire à suivre donc la case pilote
peut être bientôt sur fond de campagne
municipale
[Musique]